[Música]
tivemos a maior transformação da
história da humanidade chamada quarta
revolução industrial
uma revolução centrada em conectividade
em tecnologia e emprego nas minhas
audiências se você tivesse que escolher
entre ficar sem o smartphone ou sem um
dedo o que você escolheriam e se formos
honestos mais dedos - dedo não faz
diferença nenhuma nossa vida que não
sejam esses que segundo e digitam um
tiro dentro do pec não tem qualquer
problema agora mas eles sabem o que é a
dor de cada um de nós
todo dia quando não temos conexão quando
não temos sinal quando temos bateria vi
a coisa nos traz a uma nova realidade
tudo começou em 2007 a maior
transformação da história começou em
2007 quando uma empresa apresenta uma
coisa chamada smartphone sem a qual hoje
nós não conseguimos viver tem um monte
de gente pendurada em carregadores aqui
o power bank na parede porque nós
devemos conectados em alguma coisa e se
alguma coisa primeiro foi o iphone
depois vem a samsung lg a cheia homem e
todos nós dependemos mais ou menos de
forma permanente diária daquilo que é a
possibilidade de uma palma da nossa mão
o controlo de tudo antes 2007 eu ia no
banco o jogo no banco pelo aplicativo
eu ia na faculdade eu posso na faculdade
pelo ead
eu ia ao médico eu posso ir ao médico
pelo desapego e na casa da avó
hoje posse da casa volta o sms skype fã
daut tudo o que a avó eventualmente
possa usar
e essa mudança que não foi tecnológica
foi completamente tal tem de fato
impactado todos nós e essa grande esse
grande impacto tem a ver com coisas que
têm surgido nos últimos anos mas que há
15 anos não existiam há 15 anos não
tínhamos netflix construir ming não
tínhamos google chrome no hospital estão
digamos youtube facebook uber whatsapp
do box spotify apps store twitter após
que vai perguntar como é que a gente
vivia porque tudo isso aqui de uma forma
ou de outra está na nossa vida
hoje eu escutar música spotify eu vejo
que o netflix
eu pesquiso no google o youtube que 15
thiago já ali com os vídeos dele tão
certa forma o mundo foi transformando e
foi criando coisas que nos têm dado mais
facilidade nos conectarmos que tem
trazido mais desafios a forma como nós
vivemos trabalhamos estudamos
pesquisamos ea grande pergunta é como é
que um futuro que vem pela frente
como é que a gente se prepara para o
mundo em que a velocidade exponencial
por cada 60 segundos que passam na
internet cada minuto que passa
são 266 mil horas netflix assistidas são
1 903 mil logins no facebook
são 430 mil tweets o ponto 1 bi de likes
o dislike snutch inter por minuto é
possível ver essa gente solteira que tá
lá pra tanto lhe dislike que acontece no
final do dia da semana do mês quando
informação está sendo compartilhada
endossá da chegada reuniu fake mil ta
tudo na conversa do nosso dia a dia isso
entrou nas nossas vidas quase a gente se
notar isso a boa maioria de nós nesta
sala não pesar mas o mundo agora também
parada final de semana de carnaval
carnaval acontece nada acontece tudo
rodando na mesma velocidade
então o grande desafio que nós temos é
entender que o mundo conectado com o
mundo real são um só
olha a lista dos dez países mais
populosos do mundo o primeiro facebook
2.3 bilhões de pessoas segundo o youtube
um ponto 9 bilhões o terceiro whatsapp
1.5 e depois vem a china 1.371 nesta
lógica
depois veio o mestre do facebook 1.3
depois vem a índia possui um jet que é o
whatsapp da china pois venho está e o
brasil é o 11º da lista dos países com
mais gente
então a gente sempre fala que não tem a
noção da internet não aconteceu só no
facebook não aconteceu antes de chegar a
algum lugar que a gente faz a life story
faz o post marca as pessoas e depois a
coisa
tece eu cheguei aqui já postei no meu
estado é já postei no facebook depois
agora coisa acontece então nesta
dinâmica de transformação permanente se
pergunta mais conectar o brasil brasil
também obrigado brasil país do mundo com
mais tempo e horas gastas por dia no
celular
somos o país mais conectado do mundo na
lógica mobile então e o 3g é ruim
o 4g não pega o avaí foi lento não sei o
que é caro e apesar de tudo isso estamos
aí com para informação pesquisando
postando em do sangue fazendo toda uma
transformação acontecer em cima de uma
lógica de grande internet
o mundo é uma grande internet e esse www
sempre tem muita informação que não
interessa qual o desafio é curadoria o
que eu faço o que eu não faço no que é
que o com fio ou do que é que eu não
confio quando tô pesquisando trabalhando
estudando fazendo esse trabalho online
então a gente vive uma transformação de
www para www the world wide web apps
para o ato e homens que nós queremos
estar literalmente à distância de um
clique o celular tocando aquilo que a
mente então este ótimo antes nos dá
ele entrou na nossa vida de tal forma
que nós não sabemos o que fazer com isso
o mundo está conectado permanentemente
mesmo quando nós não estamos conectados
a gente está de alguma forma conectado
isso impacta as nossas vidas pessoais e
profissionais nosso grupo de amigos
nosso grupo de trabalho na faculdade na
empresa e tudo isso tem trazido pela
nova realidade digital em que o mundo
caminha no futuro para dependermos cada
vez mais da muda o mundo conectado
cada vez mais do mundo digital e cada
vez menos do mundo físico que a gente
goste ou não aí cada um tem sua opinião
essa é a realidade e no grande as
técnicas sempre os que é aceita que dói
menos a gente tem que saber trabalhar
nessa realidade e é isso que me proponho
trazer aqui hoje quando falo de código
10 como é que ele pode nos ajudar a
fazer a trafegar a navegar dentro desta
desta interação o conceito de futuro com
sede lá e foi a vida software e hardware
postal este é o fim
18 meses tem o iphone em domina como
ninguém spotify youtube kits netflix do
perfil dele ele aperta lá o panda já
sabe que ele e desde os oito meses game
tem uma coisa chamada fez time o que ele
mais gosta de fazer é apertar o facetime
ver que atende do outro lado
qual é o problema é que há contágios é a
minha então de vez em quando um cliente
recebendo fez sair do meu filho não sei
outro dia eu liguei de mim pra mim
porque luís rasquilha telas mas que
estão ligando pra mim apertura ele papai
papai papai do outro lado ninguém senão
isso pra ele
então este lá e fui eu desafio qualquer
um de nós nesta sala a ficar nesta
posição e conseguir interagir com um
tablet
mesmo aqueles que fazem crossfit pilates
meia maratona maratona e mail desafio
porque tem uma nova realidade humana
acontecendo a gente não é mais só seres
humanos somos seres humanos conectados
somos life foi vida software não é uma
coisa só e quando falta todo mundo
conectado tá todo mundo conectado
tá todo mundo literalmente conectar
tentando entender o que acontece nestas
caixinhas que nos conectam ao mundo e
isso nos traz um desafio adicional como
seres humanos que entender uma nova
pirâmide necessidades e saber trabalhar
com ela saber como é que eu consigo da
minha vida
viver sem a base tá você não tem
internet não consegue ouvir o que você
está falando da sala de aula não tem
bateria então vai que o mundo acaba eu
não sei eu não posso fazer o marcel
ficou mudo acabando e não estive lá
botar os amigos
então eu tenho que garantir que este
mundo onde a conexão é o mundo
permanentemente conectado
isso nos traz os maiores medos que os
nossos medos que me fascinou colecte o
aplicativo não abra e que a bateria não
dure
tudo o resto é secundário então é uma
nova lógica de olhar para os valores que
têm a ver com o futuro das empresas o
futuro do trabalho futuro das profissões
têm muito mais a ver com a nossa
capacidade criativa
de entender o contexto e mudar em função
desse contexto do que apenas saber
determinar ou definir ou dominar coisas
técnicas temos um baita desafio pela
frente que é um desafio ligado à
experimentação é um desafio ligado à
rede e ao trabalharmos e lídia
colaboração trabalhamos
colaborativamente com os outros seja lá
que eles forem temos na nossa frente o
maior desafio de todos que é trabalhar
em uma nova forma do negócio mais
resiliente mais criativo mais flexível
mais inovador capaz de correr mais
riscos não aceitar as verdades absolutas
e esse é o nosso desafio como pessoas e
como é que eu navego neste novo mundo
porque os nossos países e lamas no meu
tempo era assim dos professores falam
mas no meu tempo era assim nas empresas
em que se encontra mas sempre fez deste
jeito então a gente tá uma transformação
que não é uma luta era de mudanças
é uma mudança de era o fio filme que não
estávamos vendo acabou não subindo as
legendas finais tem um novo filme para
ser revelado novo filme para ser vivido
não temos que perguntar como é que a
gente faz isso como é que a gente entra
nesta nova era e aí vem a minha a minha
proposta de refletir juntos com vocês o
que que é isso do código 10
e aí o grande amigo meu o nosso cliente
da lei de protecção o seu código da
disney
o outro te falando e sem um erro bank
que deu no seu celular
se precisa de ajuda tem que levar uma
apple store para ver se uma loja
assistência até nada nada disso 101
eu gostava que vocês se não registrassem
nada do que estou falando aqui hoje
registram esses três números com os
erros são os 101 dias extra de
aprendizado que nós vamos precisar ter
em 2022 para continuar sendo
profissionais preparados porque tá
acontecendo a velocidade o mundo é tão
grande que se nós pararmos hoje naquilo
que é o nosso conhecimento nós saímos do
mercado os próximos dois anos
então a gente precisa adicionar ao nosso
dia a dia 21 e 22 na frente e já li no
virar da esquina elcio
estudo 30 dias por ano
eu vou ter que estudar a 131 seu estudo
100 dias por ano você está 201 e assim
sucessivamente
se eu só estudo eu tô ferrado conquistar
mais ainda
então esse é o nosso desafio professores
alunos executivos profissionais pessoas
se nós queremos estar nesta na nesta
weibe do mundo do futuro temos que
adicionar mais tempo à aprendizagem e aí
como é que a gente pode fazer isso e
beleza seja nos ferrou já vi umas caras
aqui me assustadas que a gente faz agora
como é que a gente faz isso e trouxe
cinco dicas e a primeira eu vou precisar
de fazer um exercício tão fazendo isso
aqui juntos a primeira é fortaleça a sua
rede de contatos ea sua network sempre
queria propor que se fizessem quem tem
que abra o linkedin o seu é no seu
celular
abra o link de mim tá ali vai aí ferrou
então vocês vão ficar eu vou abrir meu
tá eu vou abrir meu e você encontrar
alguém que abra o link dinho e você vai
aqui embaixo de uma coisa chamada a
pedido de amigos e lá em cima uma coisa
chamada na sua área já encontrou rodrigo
quando ele canta você rodrigo carlin
quem mais vai entrar aqui e aí se você
fizer isso você começa a ver que está na
sua rede roberta kelly roberta roberto
ali channel e roberta o patem a kátia
tênis
até natália fernanda até a juliana tem o
douglas tem rebeca e renata cecchettini
campeonato tá linda tão bem o pedro tem
a beleza
kadir natália isabella com o tempo
joão pedro carolina o ópio como é fácil
você se conectar as pessoas à sua volta
como é fácil você fortalecer o
networking e de repente um se conheceu
que não se conheça mas quanta gente pode
aprender juntos aqui
quantos de nós podem compartilhar com
outra mulher coisa e fortaleça o network
de contatos sempre dedique tempo para
aprender com os outros
essa é a primeira dica a segunda dica
e disponibilize tempo diário para se
atualizar para saber o que está
acontecendo tenho twitter tenho 12
minutos de ovar cast tem um monte de
sites que pode comprar pacotes diários
para receber informação 10 em 10 minutos
15 e 20 meia hora ou uma hora no dia pra
dar uma geral sobre o que está
acontecendo
16 do futebol do governo da geórgia
política naquilo que nos interessa
aquilo que é a minha praia eu sou um
cara de marketing que está consignado
atingiu hoje isso é de novação que a
conservação hoje façam esse trabalho de
diariamente temos há tempo para se
atualizar
não parem de estudar nessas toda a minha
linha pano de fundo foi assim né estudar
seja de forma mais estruturada seja ele
de forma nano de goes nanopilares tem um
monte de sites tem um monte de
informação hoje a informação está
disponível pra todo mundo poder
compartilhar e beber na informação então
vai lá no youtube vai nos blogs procurar
aquilo que pode complementar a
informação quando era aluno não tinha
essa possibilidade pela biblioteca da
escola estava lá
hoje eu possa voltar à escola após
pesquisa online um monte de outras
coisas que permitem manter o escopo
atualizado
questione a cultura não aceite as
verdades absolutas
há sempre foi assim beleza mas o mundo
está mudando então vamos pensar
diferente
ah mas no meu tempo era desse jeito
desculpa mas agora a gente precisa
pensar diferente então ponham em causa
de forma construtiva aquilo que são os
modelos mentais e tenham a capacidade de
navegar na incerteza
a única coisa que a gente tem garantido
no futuro é a mudança ela está
permanentemente acontecendo então
navegar nesta incerteza é interessante
porque nos permite testar coisas novas
o desafio futuro a gente vai viver o
resto da vida no futuro o passado só
serve para uma coisa a aprender com ele
nós não podemos mudar o passado mas
podemos aprender com ele as coisas boas
e as ruins ou para repetir as boas para
não repetir as ruins não foquem no
futuro se concentrem no futuro e de
certa forma
quem entre em tragam novas abordagens
não não fiquem quietos esperando que o
mundo aconteça e tem uma dica trouxe
cinco não trazer mais uma dica nacional
101 que eu botei no domingo à noite
antes de mandar apresentação o professor
vitor que é pergunta a pergunta vocês
próprios
que papel vocês querem ter vocês querem
ser o espectador que fica quieto
esperando que tudo aconteça ou vocês
querem ser os protagonistas que fazer a
transformação acontecer se eu quisesse o
protagonista eu tenho que tatuar 10 não
meu passo porque eu vou precisar estudar
permanentemente me atualizar pensar e
criar e desenvolver novas abordagens
todo dia se eu quiser ser um espectador
não tem nenhum problema mas não reclame
depois quando essa conta chegar e nós
não tivemos preparados para pagar essa
conta não só se fala se você chegou do
bairro centro e bebeu
quando a conta chega a ser paga e não
reclama 8º bec e essa é sempre a
discussão que fica como é que a gente se
prepara
perante esta realidade quero fechar com
os meus contatos sempre alertou no fim
do palco comigo há três meses atrás
aí não dava hoje pergunta você vai levar
o seu filho não hoje não é aquilo né
não tem mas se quiser ficar com os meus
contatos é fácil você sabe no celular e
fazem iskander sequer canta no japão ele
baixa direto nos a android tem que
baixar um cartão só pra pra fazer o
download e meio de um celular do que o
preço que vocês precisarem que eu possa
ajudar vocês aqui na frente uma dica uma
idéia eu fico super à disposição e se
quiserem continuar essa discussão do 101
que não pede pra sair para uma opção 01
pode passar eu acho que pede pra entrar
vamos entrar nesse jogo juntos e
transformar o mundo porque ele está
nunca na história da humanidade nós
tivemos tanta pose de transformar o
mundo como agora eu acho que isso é
importante colocar os meus segundos
finais que é os nossos pais nossos avós
nossos bisavós não tiveram oportunidade
de mudar o mundo como nós temos todos
nós nessa sala independente da idade da
classe social também estuda todos nós
temos
uma ferramenta poderosíssima na nossa
mão chamada informação que pode ser
transformada em conhecimento e esse
conhecimento devidamente aplicado pode
mudar o mundo
o bem há os que querem mudar o mundo por
mauá e cada um
depois aguenta consequência pessoal foi
um prazer estar com vocês meus contatos
agora de outra forma um pouquinho mais
estruturada felicidade muito obrigado